first name said I says Hannah it is not
about it is not about how smart you are
it's about how hard you work and you are
a hard worker and you can't teach that
and I hire people every day and I will
take a hard worker over a smart person
every day because you think about it you
do an extra two hours a day for a week
and you do that for 30 40 years the
older you get the less it matters how
smart you are the older you get your
life shows what you did the last 20 30
40 years and the winners come out from
the losers and I remember being like
whatever dad like
but this conversation stuck out to me
and it stuck out to me because
he was right he was absolutely right
like the older I get I
I ended up getting better grades than a
lot of people that were smarter than me
I ended up making more money and being
more successful than a lot of people
that were smarter than me I went further
in sports than a lot of people that were
more athletic than me and I attribute it
to my work ethic